après avoir rencontré la fédération
interprofessionnelle de la santé deux
fois en autant de semaines le ministre
de la santé a décidé de réviser à la
baisse le nombre de patients par
infirmière j'ai annoncé et madame bédard
qu'il y aura 16 projets ratio au québec
chine est aussi et c'est déjà budgétés
en faisant quelques minutes ça fait des
grands pas depuis quelques semaines
gaétan barrette promet des actions
concrètes et rapides en une semaine on
se rencontrera à nouveau pour faire pour
conclure sur les endroits où on fera le
projet ratio le ministre souhaite régler
le dossier des infirmières au moment où
l'entente avec les médecins spécialistes
soulève la grogne
les infirmières de leur côté se demande
combien d'argent leur reviendra dans le
prochain budget pour diminuer leur
charge de travail
le conseil du trésor je comprends je
comprendrais paul pourquoi que ya
toujours de l'argent pour les médecins
fille en or et pau pour les
professionnelles en soins pour la santé
et que ça bloquera le gouvernement a
tout concédé aux médecins la semaine
dernière déplore les partis d'opposition
les québécois devraient avoir leur mot à
dire
la cac et le parti québécois veulent en
débattre lors de la prochaine campagne
électorale
je mets au défi fait des couilles à deux
sous mais l'instant des spécialistes aux
québécois à l'élection du 1er octobre
prochain
ne signez pas l'entente laisser le
prochain gouvernement
décider de ce qui va se passer pour
l'avenir pour québec solidaire le
ministre de la santé ne parviendra pas à
regagner la faveur des québécois malgré
ce geste pour aider les infirmières mais
il a perdu totalement la confiance du
public
il doit partir moi je trouve que c'est
un des meilleurs mais nous à santé que
québec ait eu
pourquoi oui le son style de sa
personnalité parfois ils brassent les
choses pas mal mais y obtient des
résultats inquiétants barrette se donne
quelques mois pour évaluer l'efficacité
des projets pilotes qui vise à
déterminer le meilleur ratio patients
infirmières les résultats pourraient
donc être connu tout juste avant les
prochaines élections il si véronique
prince radio canada québec